hello everyone check this out you don't
need to know what's going on uh just
just look like tell me a joke
boom
look at that so this it's bad right it's
a distilled gpt2 model but that's not
the point the point is that I can type
something and I get back a streaming
response there is a language model and
as the language model generates tokens
it appears on your screen I have
modified a hugging face to inference
server project to get that done for
doing that I've had to go through so
many different Technologies in order to
achieve this because hogging face isn't
made to generate token by token and give
it to you at inference time also they
have built this inference server for
large language models that only at the
very end you have the hugging face stuff
before that you have grpc you have rust
you have all kinds of things and then on
top of that because this is for the open
Assistant project I wanted something
where anyone in the world could provide
their GPU and run such an inference
server so that means we have to have an
additional layer of routing that is
compatible with this streaming so what
you see right here goes from hugging
face via grpc VR rust via server sent
events via a worker python script that
connects via websocket to an inference
backend server that cues and dqs stuff
from a redis database those again being
dequeued by the same server to respond
to clients such as this text client or a
browser again via server sent events so
whenever a token is produced in the
language model it goes all of this way
directly to the client and you don't
have to wait until the very end of the
generation and then you just get one
block at a time that's what we're going
to build today
so some of you may know I've been
working on this project called open
Assistant now either there will already
be a video about it or one will come out
shortly in any case this is an open
source application of chat GPT now I'm
gonna show you all about it in that
other video today is about part of that
that I was interested in working on and
coding up and that is the inference
pipeline so for now we're doing data
collection you can interact with the
website and play the assistant and so on
but once we train the model we actually
want to deploy it so you know in chat
GPT if you enter a prompt you get the
reply in this nice streaming fashion so
token by token or word by word we want
to replicate that for one it makes the
experience more like you're chatting
with a chat bot where you can interact
with the board that's kind of you know
typing as it goes along on the other
hand it makes for a better user
experience because you get the beginning
of the message while the the end is
still Computing so we want to achieve
that however current hugging phase for
example Library only supports you
actually generate until the end so
hugging face has a server for inference
in large language models so this here is
called text generation inference it's a
repository by hugging face and it
specifically supports a bunch of the
current larger models and it also
supports sort of Homan language models
that they have on the Hub this is about
how it works so there is a rust web
server because python is notoriously bad
where you need to multi-thread so what's
the problem the problem is that we want
to serve this model here on the right
hand side with requests and this model
could be sharded on different gpus but
we want to serve it with not just one
request we want to serve it with batch
of requests so we need some sort of
batching mechanism here that means the
requests that come in must somehow be
pulled together into a batch in order to
send to the language model which also
means that these requests are no longer
independent so there must be
communication between the requests and
that communication must be quick now in
Python if I start off a new like UV corn
web server or something like this there
is a degree of parallelism which I can
reach with async IO or with different
processes I simply start the process or
lots of processes that handle these
requests the reason that works is
because the processes don't need to
communicate with each other they may
need to look some database or something
but there's no direct communication if
you need direct communication you need
threads because you need shared memory
and python does not like threads python
threads and high performance not a thing
that's why I assume that this web server
here is written in Rust however the
whole language model code the whole
hogging face library is of course still
in Python so they need to communicate 8
with python via grpc so what we want to
do is we want to modify this system we
want to add an end point at the left
hand side that essentially says generate
stream or something like this that gives
you back not just one response with the
result of your generation but sort of a
stream of results and we want to do that
through the whole mechanism of batching
through the grpc calls through the
hogging face Library all the way down
until the model so we're going to cross
all of these language and Technology
boundaries in order to make that happen
I have actually done it and this video
is me reproducing from memory what I've
done and sort of commenting it as we go
along not only that I've actually
extended that on the right hand side
here you see the original thing that you
just saw I have extended that to also
have like this little worker thing that
is now our system the open Assistant
system that communicates via a websocket
with an inference backend there is again
a redis queue that schedules that so the
workers could be anyone anyone plugging
in their GPU into the system giving
power for inference they would run the
whole thing on the right hand side and
it would probably be something like this
then communicate via websocket with the
inference backend which has a redis
system to schedule and cue the jobs and
eventually get this to the user all in
streaming fashion that means the tokens
come one by one like ding ding ding ding
ding ding from the GPU via the hugging
phase via the grpc via the rust server
Batcher via server-cent events via this
worker via websocket VIA the infras
backend via red is again through your
server sent event to the user that's it
that's what we want to do uh you might
not be familiar with some of these
Technologies I was too much you might
know the websocket so the websocket is
sort of a bi-directional push mechanism
in the web between a server and a client
it's very modern it's when you need to
go beyond HTTP requests so you just
request response every one of these
request requires a build up TLS
handshakes yada yada yada its textual
data a websocket you establish the
connection once and then you just push
events in both directions very
convenient we use that here between this
worker and the inference backend not
something for today the other technology
is server sent event now that is very
similar to a websocket but it's only in
One Direction means the client makes one
request to the server and the server
instead of responding in one go it can
send events as many as it wants until
the server closes the connection and
then that cycle is finished and the
client makes another request that's
exactly what we need in two different
places so first of all when the user
makes a request for a chat like I just
did in chat GPT that's exactly the thing
I do I send a message and then I get
back the response token by token so we
use servers and events and again here
between the worker and the web server
again the worker sends one request to do
an inference and the web server sends
back these little packets of response in
a streaming fashion so our generate
endpoint here if we end up actually
implementing it it should have a server
sent event response instead of HTTP
response and how we're gonna handle the
whole grpc thing we're gonna see we're
gonna dive into this thing right here
and the first thing we're gonna do is
obviously we're going to clone it clone
it clone it let's switch here get close
hey let me quickly jump in and just talk
to you about the fact that weights and
biases has not only been really kind to
my channel in the past but they've also
sponsored an entire team account to the
open Assistant effort open assistant is
not me it's actually a big part like a
big Community lots of volunteers doing
work I'm the person here on camera
bringing in the traffic weights and
biases has been super supportive to all
of these people and obviously there are
great mlops framework and we're super
happy to use them so I want to thank
them a lot I want to tell tell you about
this course they have it's entirely free
course so if you go to 1db.courses dot
courses is the top level domain their
courses are on effective ml Ops and this
first one is on model development so
this is a course as I said it's
completely free it's not cohort based so
you can just go through it at your own
pace here you can see a little bit of
the curriculum so it starts off with
building a prototype building a baseline
evaluating your model and going further
than that so you're not going to build
the like latest and greatest large
language model this is really taking you
from building a model and then the steps
how do I assess the quality of the model
how do I see even whether I can you know
make it better how do I treat data how
do I make things reproducible for that
you're gonna train initially a unit with
a resnet baseline so all the code is
available right here and it's all really
nice so this is in fast Ai and it's
really about this process so about how
do I know where I stand with my model
and how do I know whether or not I
improve and if I improve prove how do I
know what it was due to how do I know
the causes like which of the things that
I turn made it better and how can I make
it even more better is that a thing even
more better even better and along the
way you'll also obviously learn how to
use weights and biases as an ml op
system which is amazing because weights
and buses is the greatest envelope
system in existence obviously and it's
free forever for personal use and for
academics and for open source teams like
ours very thankful again you should
absolutely check it out it's a great way
to get started into a more principled
approach into training and improving
models than just hammering things left
and right so if you've never worked with
weights and biases this is a great
opportunity to get into it if you are at
the beginning of your machine learning
career and want to get into coding this
is also a great way to get into it and
if you just want to see kind of what the
normal steps in a data science and
machine learning engineering workflow
are this is also an absolutely great
place the course has several modules and
builds upon itself it's guided through
through as I said with Live code
examples with videos that explain
everything to you all the code is
available and as I already said it's
free so it's 1db dot courses go there
check it out and I'll see you around
[Music]
own this into HF inference all right
let's open that in code now actually I
had to make the the vs code here uh
rather large so you can see something so
forgive me for the the cram space so
what's going on right here all of this
is the repo of the text generation
inference now it's divided into two
parts there is this web server right
here and the other one is that python
part so we're gonna go into a little bit
of a dive right here so there is router
now router I'm going to assume is that
Rust part that's here called web server
and then server here let's see that
looks like python code so server I'm
gonna assume is not the thing that's
called server here on the picture but
actually the thing on the right hand
side which is the grpc server grpc for
those of you don't know it's a remote
procedure call remote procedure
something by Google that's why it's
called genes it allows you to
communicate between different processes
essentially in call methods on another
server and then get back a response very
much like HTTP but more efficient and
super duper cross-lingual alright so we
have like a server here that looks good
that looks very good so let's Analyze
That a tiny bit here we have a generate
uh thing a generate end point I want to
say so here is serve we are going to
load a model right here we're going to
add a server and we're going to add a
grpc server right here and that's gonna
serve these different requests right
here so there is generate clear cache
there's generate with cash so we want to
start like in the very very core so
let's follow this generate function
right here what does it do it parses
something from a protobuf it then calls
this thing right here generate token
okay and this generate with cash all
also calls this generate token thing
except that it does some cash thing in
front so let's go into the generate
token right here so generate token is
not implemented this is just model so
let's figure out where we are we are
somewhere models
model here we are here there are
different models the common one this
causal LM is probably the one we want we
don't want a specialized one so what's
in here there's import torch this looks
very much this looks like hugging facing
here is a batch okay this is the data
structure that has a batch to protobuf
from protobuf this looks quite good so
far okay this is the data structure
maybe there's something down here
concatenate yada causal LM okay so this
is the model and on the model there
should be a method that says generate
token there it is so this is what's
being called from both generate and
generate with cash from the endpoint
remember we are here on the right hand
side which is the hogging face code so
what does it do it takes a batch and
then it calls self.forward once yeah
once and then what does it do with the
result so here is
logins it packs in into an iterator and
it iterates over them and then it
calculates like log props and chooses
next token and so on so you might think
that this iterator right here that
iterates over the logits is iterating
over the sequence but it's not remember
this just calls forward once on the
model and we can even see what forward
is forward here just calls model dot
forward and you can see here it has like
past key values these are cached values
because in Auto regressive language
modeling you can cache a lot of stuff
and that's what it does so the iterator
is not over the sequence length but over
the batch and we're just creating one
token at a time let me show you where
that comes in handy so here
are saying this and then there is a
stopping criteria so we're going to go
through the batch we're going to have a
batch of requests and we for we create
one token for each member in the batch
and then another token for each member
now these Generations they will not be
all of the same length at the end which
means that you know for some of them we
actually need to stop generating earlier
than for others that's exactly what this
stopping criteria here it does and if
this stop is active then I guess we
decode the text we calculate some token
IDs and so on log probs and we append
here we append the generated text to the
generated texts and at the end we return
that we return it here or we return it
down here this happens inside of this
iterator so that means every time this
generate token is called we go through
each member of the batch that isn't yet
stopped we generate the next token for
it and then we decide for each member
whether or not it is stopped or not
where whether or not it should stop if
it should stop we add it to this list of
generated texts which we return at the
end of each step so at the beginning of
this inference for most members of the
batch that list is going to be empty for
most steps because that list is only
going to contain for in each step is
only going to return whatever members of
the batch were finished during that step
it's kind of clear so the list is
returned each time but it's mostly gonna
be empty so this is our point of attack
here you see the list is returned so
there is a parameter next batch keep
indices this is for caching right so
there is it returns none and if that is
true then we do some computation about
you know which indices and so on for the
next batch for caching but we still you
can see right here we still return the
generated text
so since we create all the tokens I
think what we should do is we should
simply return something more right here
with each step and that is for each
member of the batch the generated tokens
no matter whether it's finished or not
and then we can still return once
they're finished we can still return the
full result at the very end so we're
going to stream stream once it's done
we're gonna return the full thing and
then it's you know really done okay so
let's go after this generated text thing
right here what is that that appears to
be some data class it has a two protobuf
we won't care about this right now what
we'll do is we'll simply make another
date to class right here that's like
intermediate intermediate well just call
it intermediate
so this here maps to the request because
it needs to know which request it comes
from since we're gonna return whenever
something is stopped that list doesn't
necessarily map one to one to the
request I don't want to really put in
the entire request every time we emit
the token so let's just say we're gonna
put the request ID here I happen to know
that that's a string we'll look at that
later what and how and why and Proto
actually
let's look at it now so in the protobuf
definition if you've never seen
something like this this protobuf is is
just you specify interfaces data
messages you specify apis and so on so
here you can see request the ID is
indeed not a string so good that we
looked it up and the generated text
right here you can see that's the
corresponding protobuf you can see the
request is of type request yeah so
request ID is an integer
let's do that that's an INT good output
text no generated tokens no now we could
do a lot of things right here but in
essence I just I just want I just want
the token we could give the log problem
the token ID and whatnot but for now I
just want the token uh we can extend it
later all right so let's make a list
intermediates here or import that
all right let's see where we produce
that we produce that here if stop the
question is I don't actually I want I
don't want it I want it I want to add it
no matter whether stop or not so here
you see we take the next token we
squeeze it a bit and we decode it so now
slowly we come into the question of we
have to try it out somehow right we
can't just sit here and just reason
about it and think about it this is
python after all we're meant to run it
so there is a readme right here and the
readme says how exactly you can run this
thing so here it says okay uh if you
want to if you want to develop it you
need to make these things actually you
probably want to make install first so
let's do it open the terminal
foreign
so this will build pretty much all the
things if you are working with rust I
suggest you get yourself the rust
analyzer that's very neat all right all
right we're done with the first part
make install then we make server depth I
think that's it server Def and router
depth by default this loads like some
some blue model which I don't
necessarily want so let me try to change
that server Dev here
make CD server make run Dev so the make
file of the server makes
here serve big science Bloom we don't
want that that's kind of a a large model
so we're at the hugging face Hub let's
see let's go text generation most
downloads that sounds good we need
something small distill GPT sounds to be
decently small very small let's see it's
300 megabytes
how uh models models all right let's
grab it the still gpt2 let's replace
this all right here we go go back to our
terminal we split it a bunch of times
make server Dev split it alright model
name distill gpt2 error fantastic it
already starts absolutely great let's
see what do we have sharded is not
supported for auto model yeah we don't
want sharded and and and
excellent we're running okay the server
is running let's
um split the terminal here make router
death this is going to compile some Rust
code and then start up this router and
lastly if we split that again the readme
here in case you can see it gives us a
nice way of how to test it we take this
curl command so this says connected so
we'll plug the curl command here yeah
testing API new line new line new line
new line new line if I do it again I'll
get the same so the original text is
testing API and we're getting new line
new line new line new line new line that
that is a great response absolutely so
here you also see that that is the
response everything works as we expected
so let's make this uh great make this
awesome the first thing we want to do is
actually we want to go in here and
really see what this next token thing is
we're going to do some small small
optimizations and say next token
squeezed is that and all right
like this and we also need the result of
this decode thing so let's take that up
here
um next token
decoded and I realize there's a comma
which is deadly in Python and we're
going to print
and my favorite thing to do is just to
do this
so I can actually I can actually find it
in an output especially if you have lots
of output so we want to do that let's
bring up the terminal again look at that
well there's nothing different because
we haven't restarted it yet so the
question is which one do we need to
restart and I'm gonna guess the one on
the left that's kind of the Python one
kill it as hard as we can run it again
we should be good as song as this says
and it failed to bind to uh it's it's
crashing okay why
um
good we're up I guess it blocked its own
port and start the router and then start
the curl command and we should see we
should see this thing right here so
there's ah obviously this is the new
line token right and then there is a
tensor with one item so this next token
decoded is simply the token we're
looking after so that's very good so we
can simply add that to the intermediates
so intermediates append we want to
append actually an intermediate with the
request ID equals the request ID and I'm
pretty sure that wasn't called request
ID in the Proto it was just called ID
yes see here so in protobuf Python will
actually generate a code for you which
is pretty neat so these will just end up
as python objects that you can access
stuff of and token equals the next token
decoded and that's good so we append
intermediate and we go here to the
return we return the intermediates along
with the generated text let's go to the
next return statement also return that
here so whether it's with the next batch
cached or without we're going to always
return these intermediates so now we
want to find out where this function is
called We Now grab all of the tokens as
they're happening we return them every
time as opposed to only returning the
Finish things so we need to figure out
where this generate token is being
called and as you can see it's being
called in a bunch of this is tests we
don't care about tests who writes tests
tests are for wussies weak people right
sorry tests are fine so here as I said
before it's only here in the generate
and the generate with cache methods here
yes intermediates and let's let's see
what what to do with them so that the
second call is just down here right
we'll deal with that later so what do we
we do with the fact when we get back
these intermediates so this is packed
into this generate response object and
then sent and that's happening every
time right even if that generated text
thing is empty so we can abuse that we
can just piggyback on that and also also
pass through these intermediates so here
we do that and here I'm gonna guess just
the same yeah so here also that would go
come here and go here
yes easy as that all right so we get
these intermediates and we'll just go
with the like with the generated text
right here let's say yep generated text
to intermediate copy paste
excellent and grab the intermediates
here wonderful wonderful now we have a
problem namely this object here has no
clue what we're passing into right and
this is one of these protobuf objects as
I said protobuf you define it in these
Proto files and then the protobuf
compiler will create the necessary
objects for you in the languages that
you desire in this case in Python so it
will make python objects in order to
interact with with products it's like a
code generation compiler so you can just
write your programming language you and
simply fill out fill up these these um
objects right here so the IDE here is
it's it's kind of an indie IDE vs code
not sure if you know it but it doesn't
seem to work too well with these
generated things or maybe I was just I'm
just incompetent at handling it I'm
pretty sure you can make it do somehow
in any case what we need to do is we
need to find this generated text thing
um no not the generated text here
generate response and generate with
cache response these two objects they
need to have next to generated text
lists they need to have intermediate
list however these are of object
generated text which is this thing right
here again like we did in Python we
should make an intermediate intermediate
and this is you and request ID we called
it token request ID token token that's
it now in the generate response we grab
this
mediate result why not
intermediates
intermediate
copy paste good alright so far so good
now as you might have seen there in the
generated text python class there is a
method to convert it to one of these
protobuf objects so we need to do the
same thing for the intermediate now this
is fairly easy it's just take data put
data but we need to implement it let's
see yes
oh
go Pilots I love when this happens
wonderful wonderful so far so good cool
let's let's just you know let let's just
can we try it out where does this crash
that's my my question right here where
can I see the the terminal I am a really
knock toggle pan oh oh what's that
command J Wow I I legit did not know
that okay the question is does this
crash and if not can we make it such
that somewhere we actually see this so
here there's the generate response I
still don't we're still not sure when
the generate and when the generate with
cash is called right so let's
um here print generate and intermediates
and down here we print of course thank
you co-pilot so let's print those stuff
out and see what happens make this
server make the router the router can't
find the server the server is blocked on
some Port of course that is always
lovely oh no okay so we get some error
that's fantastic
okay how about that failed something
failed okay there is class intermediate
is somehow not good has no attribute
intermediate so we've only defined the
protobuf now the make files aren't too
comprehensive here so we might need to
start from the top and run make install
again to actually compile the protobufs
while that's happening we can actually
confirm that that is make install goes
into this install server we go to the
server make file we see that they're
compiled produce gen server gen server
is run from install yes so if we just
run the server it will not recreate the
protobuf so we need to run make install
in order to create the protobuf
definitions now here oh yeah see here
you see the generated things they're in
git ignore but it's useless to try to
read them because it's like yeah no this
string right here is the generated thing
no thank you all right we can just go
ahead and make the server
router we need to wait for the server to
be started and fail to bind to address
still all python 3. let's see if you're
still so unhappy oh come on build to
bind well I guess we'll just need to
wait until that socket is free again
well okay let's change stuff a bit how
about rock per node one all right that
looks better and make the router all
right we have it back up and let's make
our curl request okay so we got a bunch
of stuff right here we get the same
response as you can see I hope you can
see we do actually first get a generate
request and then we get generate with
cash after that for each token so we
need to be able to handle both but it's
good to know that it first calls the
generate and then I guess once it gets
back a response and it does some caching
it then says generate with cash to to
use the fact that the cache is there yep
generate with cash you also see the
intermediates the token is in fact that
new line token the request ID matches I
don't know exactly whether I am maybe
here not sure you also see something
interesting the generate request which
we'll get to later actually has this do
sample parameter and sort of top K and
temperature and so on so this is what
currently makes it deterministic but
later we actually want to control the
sampling parameters and also introduce a
random C but I don't know if we got to
that today so now we know how it works
and we know what we're doing and so on
so let's go to the server thing where we
have our print statements these two
people these two protobuf also seems to
work there seems to be no complaints
about that so we have the python thing
done right the python thing is pretty
easy and what also has become clear is
that if we quickly go back to here the
Rust part here is calling the python
code for every single token so it's like
generate get something back generate
with cash get something back generate
with cash get something back so the
actual processing of that outer while
loop which usually would also happen in
hogging face code but in this particular
case that actually happens inside the
rust server so let's get rusty as the
kids say these days we'll close all of
that python stuff we don't We're not
gonna need it anymore and let's see
where the rust stuff is so here's the
Proto and I think here in the router so
every Bros project has this cargo Tamil
finds a bunch of stuff you can see here
the binary is at Main the lib is at lib
the main file to to import let's see
what happens at this uh there's a bunch
of arguments for example tokenizer name
oh there's a tokenizer look at that
there is the server run there is a
client the client is like awaited that
looks like something I want to know
where this here here is a generate
request okay that's one that comes from
and also we need generate with cash
request
so generate with cash request here this
is the interface in the protobuf we need
to know where these two things are
called and it seems to be here so in
client.rs there is generate with cash
it's a function it takes in batches it's
a method actually of this client thing
so there is a thing called client which
we are already solving for and that's
the thing that interacts via grpc with
the python code connect which is good
service Discovery clear cache generate
and here we see generate with cash and
these simply call the grpc thing so
these are the rust function that the
rust code would call in here these
things in turn called grpc functions
that run on the python side so here is
where in this generate requests the
generate response that we get should
contain intermediates let's try that out
so we'll just modify the Gen generate
thing right here and we'll print not the
response but intermediates let's let's
see how that works I just want to see
I'm not sure if we need to recreate the
produce or something like this for rust
as well I just want to see how that
works now since we are not modifying the
python code anymore too much this one I
want to make this one I am I suck I suck
at this I all right I don't actually
need to show the hole so I just need to
restart this Rust part right here and
Okay add a semicolon thank you rust
compiler is very nice if you don't know
rust I didn't then I learned it it's fun
let's see all right connected
and you can see we have intermediate
here excellent so from here we were
actually able to print these
intermediates that come from grpc now we
never defined anything in Rust to make
that happen and we were wondering where
so if you look at it this is actually
generated code that the protobuf
compiler generates puts here into the
generate V1 RS thing and you can see
that now here this struct intermediate
this is a rust struck that the Proto
buff compiler has made for us and that
will be the result when we call the grpc
method so there's a request ID and there
is a token and hopefully the request ID
up here that we get in is also a U6 are
excellent cool so we get these
intermediates right here now we get
really into rust stuff as you can see
here the returns the last line if it
doesn't have a semicolon it's a return
statement here you can see we return
okay and then we return a tuple this
okay here is a rust construct that's
called a result the result can have
either an okay value or an error value
so it's a bit different concept than
just raising some exception so your
return type is always is result not
always but in you can make it result in
which case the caller always needs to
handle well if it is actually okay then
this and if it's not okay then I do
something else you can see right here
the return value is a result this is the
okay type if you don't say anything the
error type which would come here is
simply like a generic error oh sorry
this this entire thing is the OK type so
if we want to return our response bonds
dot intermediates right here the rust
compiler will hopefully tell us wait a
minute that's not the correct type I
expected something else expected and
then we need to change this up here so
we need to actually say I'm going to
return a vector of intermediate and then
compiler is happy again again here
response intermediate the result the
return type we adjust cool the question
is we have not actually imported this
but we have a star import here in all of
the generated protobuf things all right
we're one step closer the question is
now obviously where are these functions
called this generate function and for
that Russ is actually pretty decent
support Ides so simply say show me all
the references there is only one
reference so this is in a thing that's
called sharded climb so the sharded
client calls the client the sharded
client has a generate function and a
generate with cache function that in
turn simply clone called the in the
client thing now again our task is
simply to pull through here what that is
so the Imports here are actually
explicit so we need to ah okay so that
is unexpected we can't import this we
can't unresolved import that's
interesting let's see so generated text
is a pub struct intermediate is also a
pub struct we should have no problem
importing that maybe that will just go
away by itself once we recompile so
let's see where that's returned add the
return type here and do the same down
here now the problem is obviously we
can't test that for a while until we
actually are able to run it now we need
to figure out where that sharded client
is called so it's gonna get more
interesting I promise so the references
and this is called here in the Batcher
so the a Batcher here it has generate
and down here it also has generate so it
has a bunch of calls to the generate and
maybe also here the generate with cash
it has a bunch of things see here this
goes into rap future this goes into rap
future and this goes into rap future so
maybe we can do something here here you
see we get this which looks suspiciously
like what we returned so let's just try
to intermediate and that is not known
let's say where is the generated text
let's just intermediate let's just try
that let's see that's the future that
comes in future here this also
intermediates
so you can see right here these are the
two values and that and here that should
work right all of this we simply drop
the intermediates here or we actually we
can print them print them right here and
we don't do anything with them so now we
are we have sort of a stable
configuration or a configuration that
should be stable okay no intermediate in
the root question is do we need to
rebuild something and so let's try nope
okay unresolved Import in Charlotte
client unresolved import here so from
the crate we can't import like the batch
client do I need to somehow say which
things are re-exported that's sort of
beyond my level of rustiness we we just
copied everything let's see I have so
here there is a build RS now the build
script in Rust you just make a rust
script that's called on build the
problem is it's gonna try the only
rebuild when something changed so the
issue is maybe we haven't changed enough
things not sure let's delete this let's
delete this and just try to Cargo build
no no no no no that's even worse
uh
okay I figured it out as I said the
client crate creators like module is
inside the router creating the client
crate decides what it exports and it
does that in this lib RS thing which so
far I have not considered so here we can
see all the things that are exported now
all that's left to do is intermediate at
that here yeah we're importing It Anyway
already so this is the important and
also the export by saying Pub that
should fix our problems here that should
fix our problems here that should make
this run and yes it does it wasn't a
protobuf issue after all good so the
router looks like it's running yeah we
get something something look at that
nice neat so we get intermediates these
things we get them at one place in this
rap future now here is where the trouble
starts right the the the real deal
really troubly bubbly we get them in
this rap future sure where was that here
rap future yes so this is a future as
you can see now we're getting into
asynchronous things right these are
threads they communicate they are
asynchronous and so on so how what and
why and what and how here you can see if
you have we we await this future we get
these things and then we pass that
through send generated now send
generated on itself is taking the
finished generated text it's taking
entries that map request IDs to request
entries and it's sort of mushy bushes
them in and responds but only for the
finished ones we don't want that we
actually want to make this for all of
the intermediates as well so again the
strategy is we're gonna take this here
so we're gonna
intermediates we're gonna take a vac of
intermediate thank you co-pilot and
we're gonna to pass it here
intermediates now what do we do with
them here you can see we iterate over
the finished ones and then we send them
to this thing here is where it gets
interesting this response TX right here
that is as the IDE tells me Ascender now
a sender is a concept in roster of a
channel you have channels you have
sender receiver and so on this
specifically I think is a One-Shot
Channel if you see here the response TX
is a sender and the sender is from a
One-Shot channel so you open a channel
you listen and your sender sends one
thing and then the channel is closed
that's how you do cross thread
Communication in Rust yeah the question
is like we can start doing the same
thing so intermediates into iter by the
way if you see into in Rust it's sort of
the type conversion also handles like
movement of data and so on and it's
pretty cool but I don't have the time to
explain Alco pilot is gonna suggest a
giant same thing for me right here but I
really I want a bit of control over this
so sorry co-pilot button you can't
and the other cool thing so this here
we're gonna we're gonna do a Lambda
function and let's say what they do
right here into iter for each yeah so
we're gonna do something for each
intermediate result this is a Lambda and
you don't need to specify a type here
because the compiler knows what type it
is and very often in Rust you can just
leave away the types which is really
cool so the first thing they do now we
get into the real batching so the
Batcher has these entry things it's
called an entry and an entry we can
quickly look at what that is so an entry
it's just a map from u64 to 20 oh that's
the entry that's kind of like the
database an entry struct has a request
the response Channel and some data so
the database keeps this these um entries
and we now need to get this entry from
the database let's say this is how you
do it we just copy that pretty Shameless
now the output here has a request but we
don't have a request we just have a
request ID which makes things actually
simpler so we say intermediate dot
request ID here we get a complaint it
says I expected a reference to an
integer and I got an integer so we
actually or another reference a borrow
in rust is called a borrow rust is very
good at knowing when data moves and when
it doesn't move and it doesn't let you
do things that would jeopardize the
safety like the memory safety of things
which is a really cool feature so or it
mostly doesn't let me that you can write
on say for us but
um and then this remove here gives us
what's called an option so an option is
very similar to a result an option is
like optional in Python where it can be
something which in Rust it's called sum
of something or it can be none so we'd
have to handle both cases but since
we're relatively sure that none will
never happen which will be a bug we can
call this expect thing which just means
that this would actually panic if none
ever happens and panic is like super
duper exception everything crashes you
only really want to do this if you're
sure that never happens so we have that
entry and now here they build this big
infer response and send that via the
channel we should replicate that instead
of the infer response here
um there is this is a a struct what we
should do is we build our own struct
that is like an intermediate response
puppet truck intermediate
response and sure let's do that request
ID well the request ID is already given
we don't need that anymore in fact we
would just need a string but we want to
be able to extend that later so I'll
just say that's a token which is a
string that is never constructed that's
fine I'm gonna probably derive debug
derived these are macro or I think
preprocessor directives not entirely
sure in any case we let the response be
not this infer response but we let it be
the intermediate response and brick no
it just has the token which is the token
from the thing we get okay all good it's
just a bit of data processing so far now
we have to send it via the channel and
that's the problem so the response
Channel as I said is a one shot Channel
it means that it can only receive one
thing let's see where it is constructed
and why that's a problem so we go to
references we see where is that
constructed in the Batcher here here
it's constructed so when the re when the
infer is called from the web server we
append to the database which is just
this map right we append this entry with
the response channel the response
channel is created up here and is a
One-Shot Channel once we have that we
are going to listen to the receiver so
this is the sender that we pass and we
stay with the receiver and we just wait
for the receiver to have data and then
we return that data and the channel is
gone that's not gonna work in our case
right in our case we need to be able to
continuously send data until it's
finished so how do we do that we can
either go from the inside out or from
the outside in let's see so in the entry
we probably need another channel right
here now the one shot Channel isn't
gonna do it because that's one shot so
we need something better so rust
multi-producer single consumer Channel
that's what it's called like the
standard Channel it here is rust by
example you can see here we make a
channel that's going to give us a sender
and a receiver yeah that's essentially
what we are going to need so let's
import the mpsc module let's see right
here we'll probably we should go from
the outside here where we actually
created so also this Tokyo here it's a
library for doing like threading in
channels so let's try that this is the
response channel so let's
intermediate the X and intermediate make
Channel and I want to make this an
unbounded channel so no limit that means
we can't just await it right but we'll
care about that in just just a bit so in
the entry now we're going to pass next
to the response transmitter we're also
going to pass an intermediate
transmitter probably want to use this
intermediate response right here and we
don't want to just do that we actually
want to return a result and not just a
response by itself like if there's an
error we have to handle it so error
result
intermediate response lined error just
like here right I'm gonna not do the
whole dock string right here because I'm
lazy yeah so when we construct this is
obviously not a mistake we're gonna pass
in this intermediate transmitter right
here okay so this is an unbounded sender
and here we just have a sender that's
obviously unbounded sender there we go
and it correctly says that it is never
red so let's go to where this is
actually red where were we here yes okay
so here we don't know what to do with
the response now let's just send it or
via that channel right let's grab the
entry let's grab the intermediate TX and
let's send this and this unwrap or
actually we don't need to unwrap or but
yeah this will here returns again a
result and we again say here we don't
say expect we don't want to crash but if
the receiver is gone if the result is an
error we simply want to say well
whatever because the receiver is is gone
so we send here in this Loop we
essentially send in to the channel and
the data flies away now we need to
handle it on the other side
um how do we do that we can't just wait
right we don't know how many are gonna
come so we need some sort of signal that
it's now over and that's where it comes
in handy that we have this intermediate
response right here what we can do is we
can say well here this token is actually
not a string it's an indie there's also
an indicator of whether it's uh the the
end so we're going to make a Boolean is
end we're going to do that and we're
gonna make that false most of the time
and we're gonna make it true and just
send empty string or something like this
we could make this optional but then
we'd always have to handle sort of the
non-optional case so we'll simply say
the response here is is and is false and
once we're done here we're gonna send an
is and true ah but we don't know the N
tree well see that gets it gets tricky
yeah we need to pull this through from
way before because we call the hogging
face code and it doesn't necessarily
know does it know when things are
finished ah okay now here we know
something is finished right so here we
should send before we send the infer
response we should send a signal to the
intermediate thing that it's actually
done so here we send okay but we send
intermediate response yes yes yes this
is good and string there's there's
multiple kinds of string in Rust oh come
on string from from yeah good don't know
what's going on so now we send is and
false right and then as soon as this
thing is finished we get the
corresponding entry and send well by the
way now no more intermediate things are
coming so you can proceed to listen to
the actual response uh Channel and
therefore here we can simply listen to
the intermediate channel the
intermediate receiver we can probably we
need to do while true or something now
blocking receive a call receive I'll
just let's just do that okay so we can
safely unwrap here can't borrow as
mutable ah the receiver is mutable so we
make this mutable
unused result so they here map the error
let's just do the same handling of the
result like this question mark question
mark is pretty neat in Rust very good
just put question mark it will work
promise so this is receiving actually
one thing so we need to put this into a
loop let's say so this here will give us
an intermediate response right this is
an intermediate response intermediate
response now we need to put this into a
loop and listen for as long as the is
end isn't coming so if intermediate
response is and I want to say break
good if it's not the end let's just
print it okay let's print it even before
and see what happens we haven't run
something in a while okay has is never
the trade debug is ignored during that
code okay and we get an empty reply this
is a bug this is oh no the thing I said
would never happen it happened oh why oh
why we we actually ran into the into the
this is this is a bug let's see
unbounded sender is a bug oh of course
so we remove we remove the entry because
we only gonna use it once in the
original case we actually remove the
entry from the hash map and then use it
that's obviously not something we want
and in fact we should see one output
before that crash happens here yeah one
happened and then we removed it and then
we didn't find it anymore so good good
thing we noticed so we don't don't want
to actually remove it we just wanna get
it so I don't know this hash map have
like some sort of get get oh yeah cool
um get so it will not get us it will get
us a reference to the entry whereas
remove as you can see here got us the
entry itself because we actually take
ownership of the object and now we get
we don't get ownership of the object we
simply get a reference a borrow what
it's called that should work now so we
should be able to see all of these
intermediates
bam nice is and false false false false
false false false and then at the end
true beautiful beautiful all right let's
we are on a roll we're on a roll and
we're not gonna stop okay the question
is now this is made request response
from the outside one request goes in
here to infer response returns that we
need to be able in between to send stuff
out right challenging how do we do that
I propose holes again we use channels so
let's see where is infer actually called
it's not called in this file so let's go
to references it's called once in server
twice twice so first it's called in
liveness check okay we can leave it at
that that's fine and then it's also
called in here look at that generate
there's a function called generate
there's none called generate with cache
because that's kind of done internally
right there is a function called
generate that calls infer here gets a
response and then it ships that response
out with yada yada yada conversion
headers something something something
response right this here is in fact the
HTTP server I'm gonna it's because here
I Define an HTTP router and I attach to
the generate path this function this
generate function so what we want to do
is we want to make another one we want
to keep the ability of the users to call
generate as an HTTP request and get back
an HTTP response but also we want to
have a function called like generate
stream and that should do a different
thing it should call generate stream a
different function and it might not be
the most beautiful thing in the world
but we're just gonna take all of this
and copy paste it and then make the
bottom function here into the one that
we want so stream now we're gonna delete
most of the stuff right this is just a
concept for now we can introduce it
again we don't want instrumentation on
this stuff so the result we're gonna
have to see how we do this yeah okay
start time I don't particularly care but
total time Q time time per token headers
and so on all of this is gonna drop
we'll make it really easy really easy so
um
yeah then details we don't need to
return token details at all we just need
this infer response right validate
requests so details does details go
somewhere
yeah no no no this input length
validated request that goes into infer
that seems fair that seems quite Fair
there is a permission like model is
overloaded that's fine too start time
isn't needed anymore okay so now let's
worry about what we actually need to
return here we return a generated text
and that generated text comes from this
lib RS that's then serialized to Json to
be sent out we want to return not this
but we want to return we want to return
intermediate let's just call it like
that and let's make this a token and
that's that cool so we want to respond
that however we don't want to respond
with like respond with an HTTP response
we want to respond with a server sent
event Stream So this here uses axum
which is like a rust HTTP or a Rost web
server we're gonna try to search for
rust SSE and we find the documentation
you can see that we simply return a
stream this gets into a little bit of
the weeds but essentially re-return a
stream we need to return this SSE right
here so that the server knows
essentially the wattage that it
shouldn't return an HTTP response so
generate stream here should not return a
result but instead should return SSE and
you can see rust is very helpful thank
you SSE of something that implements
stream stream yes the item is a result
yes of event event is again from SSE
event or infallible so this is not gonna
fail alright so what we need to do we
don't need to return one of these and
you can see immediately some of these
questions marks popping up red and
that's because we are not handling
errors anymore correctly so there's
multiple things we can do and the
easiest is just to ignore them
don't do this at home but we just say
expect and we just crash whenever an
error happens can we can we not do that
can we unwrap
no why not okay now let's just assume
this is never overloaded problem solved
I'm sorry I'm pretty sure expect should
like work alright it works here I'm I'm
not sure why it didn't didn't above we
can like we can we can try here it said
what it said that this thing right here
hasn't doesn't have debug it could have
debug all right good good I I want to
expect here okay this here now what we
should do is we should actually send
some sort of error event right we should
Define some sort of protocol where we
send but we no we don't wanna we don't
wanna do this we just wanna assume this
never ever fails so good then here
expect inference error that's fine okay
now it comes to so our event data that
we want to send is this is this we have
this generated text right here right and
we have this intermediate just below we
import this we create that intermediate
so that's infer response we'll see in a
bit how we do this
we'll see technically yeah I don't know
yet exactly what we have to return is a
stream and here you can see how to make
such a stream so this is a stream that
will just say hi a lot of times import
let's do that import does this work why
not declared
duration no this should work ah good
import yeah stream is the wrong Stream
So this we get futures we got Tokyo use
Futures stream how about this does it
work now
um we should probably also import some
stuff this we have this here Tokyo
stream maybe and this ah okay I see how
about will you import this and Tokyo
stream doesn't exist and here I have
less and less of a clue what I'm doing
yes self and stream okay so we don't
have Tokyo stream if we go here to axon
feature Flags
Tokyo
features full okay do we have Tokyo here
features full how about that how about
that look at that it works I have no
clue I mean probably I can remove those
but there are if we go to Tokyo stream
net here enables Tokyo net types and
stream have been moved into the Tokyo
stream crate
ah no it doesn't work okay so there is a
Tokyo stream crate which we can install
tokenstream zero one eleven alright
that's gonna that's gonna be it so we
remove this here and we're going to go
we're gonna go
we're going to go here to the router and
we're going to say cargo add Tokyo
stream all right let's see whether that
fixed anything it seems it did but we
still have problems import stream
Futures yes I think I did this wrong yep
okay if we did everything correctly now
then we should technically get a stream
that just says hi hi but we have to call
not the generate endpoint if we call
generate we get our usual thing but if
we call generate stream see hi hi hi hi
hi we get back a stream nice so this is
this is like a we are now continuously
listening until the server caps like
cuts the connection which it doesn't do
because it just goes on forever but this
is how we make a stream this is pretty
neat so how do we use that what we need
is we need the chat Channel and we need
to make it into a stream so first of all
with this infer right here I want to
actually I wanna put in a channel so the
channel I don't want to create in the
infer but I want to create the channel
outside and pass it to infer so infer is
gonna take an optional Channel or we
could make some infer stream which is
also possible I opt for the easier thing
I guess so here I want to say this takes
intermediate
um but the problem is does my plan work
no
so let's assume we create the channel
out of this then we run this and since
this is async we will never get to like
the notify Point okay I haven't made up
my mind yet but let's try it out so we
pass in this intermediate uh channel so
TX which thank you unbounded this that's
perfectly fine and then we create this
out here right so here let's create that
channel to listen to I have a feeling
that's this isn't gonna go too well is
we are awaiting a whole bunch of stuff
no this is definitely not gonna go well
um yeah no not gonna go well so we need
a infer stream function that acts as a
pondant that's a fancy word to the infer
so infer
um stream this doesn't actually need to
be async so in first stream simply makes
the request and Returns what does it
return it doesn't return a response it
actually just enqueues this doesn't do
this whole looping it doesn't do this it
just notifies the task and it returns I
want to say maybe maybe it can return
the intermediate the intermediate and
the response channels yep yep so we are
going to return these two
fine
that sounds reasonable ish now here this
is no longer reasonable ish where's the
mistake where is the mistake here is the
mistake so the entry here
um actually let's make that
option
let's make that here infer make that
none we don't need it
yes option
oh and let's not have this Loop here in
fact let's have that in somewhere here
we'll decide later where what to do with
it but let's only do this if we have
actually a channel if let TX let some
[Music]
that's fine
perfect so we only send if there is a
channel otherwise we we don't that seems
reasonable ish good now up here
obviously we have this some
okay
and now it's not happy with us this is
slowly getting complicated so it is not
happy about the return type here and I
probably was a bit too quick so the
return type we want the intermediate one
to be an unbounded receiver over
intermediate I guess it uh infer
response I see I see yeah that makes
sense result of infer response and this
is the result of intermediate response
how about that now we are good okay so
now the server needs to handle all of
that so in generate stream we first
validate all of this
um this we can on comment here we need
to call in for stream
with this and we don't get a response in
fact we get two channels so we don't
need this we don't need that we don't
need this we in fact want intermediate
receiver and response receiver
good and now we do we do the loopy loop
so we do this we put it here we
uncommented and
import import
that maybe and here we have a response
intermediate response again we obviously
simply make this really easy for
ourselves and we delete this
okay unbounded receiver is mutable
we should get all the intermediates and
then we should get a stream that says hi
hi let's do this let's get our curl
ready and
okay so we get this and then we say hi
hi hi excellent so now the only thing
that's left to do we're trying to get
this channel responses into this stream
thing now I for one I have no clue how
to do this efficiently but I'm pretty
sure the internet does so there we go so
in Tokyo stream there is async stream
that seems like so here is a channel and
we make that into a stream it seems okay
uh we'll copy this
um here let's install it Pargo add async
stream
yes good thank you cargo okay so all we
need to do is we need to do the
intermediate receiver we receive stuff
from it and now obviously everything
goes everything goes
why why is that mismatch resolving async
stream impulse future found expected
found expected intermediate response
found event
so we have to translate this item into
an event what is the item the item is an
intermediate response or an error so
again we don't worry about error
handling uh let so let's say let
response equals item
Dot
expect sure now we need to return an
event
does that work no that doesn't that
can't work
how about
event what do we need for this event
we'll just go till we find an example
that does it for us where do we get an
event there we go event ah we had that
before how dumb how dumb
am I event default and we just we want
to transform this into Json so let's
Json
how about that destruct Json from
request no we don't have a converter to
Json for this we need this third Json
and we need to string from that okay use
okay some
all right still not good enough how how
tight mismatch async stream as stream
expected event found result of event so
this gives us an event we need a result
of an event
about we yield okay of this
wow almost serialize is not implemented
for intermediate response
serialize is not implemented but it is
it is I see it right here ah this isn't
this is intermediate this isn't
intermediate response so
um
[Music]
like this and will
do that how about this cannot find
intermediate resp
like this
oh come on
yes
that's that oh intermediate
I'm getting stupid what this is all okay
so we get the channel we convert it to
an async to a stream right we read from
the intermediate channel and we yield
okay and we get an event with the data
that's this here is an SSE event this is
a stream of events and now we return the
stream down here so this was a long
thing but hopefully hopefully if
everything worked out correctly which it
always does in programming we compile
this okay and then we should get back
just the intermediate events and we deal
later
okay we don't get
we don't get anything we get the tokens
over here because we print oh look at
that we still have the the loop thing
here of course we exhaust the channel
right here right we don't need this Loop
thing so here we get we should get the
first we should get the very no while
yes while some item okay item is what
intermediate is is is is is what
what type is it intermediate response ah
so we need to check whether it's an end
if
is and
then break if this works
yo
so instead of iterating through the
channel beforehand we now iterate
through the channel in this async stream
right here and as we do we emit these
tokens and if we are at the end we just
break the connection at which point the
client knows look at this
yeah and uh if in the parameters here we
specify for example
um do sample
and we say that's false
then we get the same thing but if we say
do sample is true
then we get different things look at
that with x i o soy
seven and something
so it would obviously be neat if at the
end we get also the full response right
which we can also do so after this while
loop we could go into another while loop
that goes that just waits for the
response like for the response channel
uh this this whichever we're getting we
don't need these details
um yeah this response channel right here
and we could convert that to Json as
well and send that but in essence that's
it that's that that's that's that we now
converted we pulled all the way through
from the hugging face called vogrpc via
the rust Patcher via streams and asyncs
and channels up until server sent events
um yeah now I just want to show you as I
said I've pulled this further so we were
only doing this part right here in in
the picture up until this server sent
events right here if you pair this with
websockets and redis and user right here
you can do pretty cool things so in the
open Assistant repo I have the inference
folder and there's like a script that
opens a tmux so you need tmox you need
Docker but this will open a bunch of
panels right here on the left side is a
redis this here is the server we just
built packed as it as a Docker container
also with distill GPT here is our own
inference back end that does the routing
between workers and users as I I said
workers can be anyone on the world can
essentially plug their worker into our
system via a websocket so here now you
can see we've loaded up the model yes so
we are connected this has no pending
task this is a worker that runs this
right here so the worker is connected to
this and connected via websocket to this
and here on the very side over I have
the user and that's a little text front
end so I wanna I wanna show you what
happens when I type something here hi
how is it going
and what you get is a streaming output
as the tokens are produced I have a
little prompt here that that is
essentially a user assistant
conversation but it's this still gpd2
and I don't do termination so you can
see when here you this is actually
output from the model tell me a joke
let's see
yeah
so that's what you get you get a super
distributed Network where anyone can
plug in their GPU to the system we have
the central thing with redis and people
run at home they run this this uh
inference server that we just built and
all of it is streamed so whenever that
thing produces a single token that is
streamed via grpc VIA rust via server
sent events via websocket VIA redis and
again via server sent events to this
client right here which obviously then
could also be your browser and that is
the final thing that we wanted to get
yeah uh that's that's
um it thank you for being here uh I know
this was long let me know if you want
more of these coding videos
um we get into the depth of things and
figure out what we need to do where as I
said video on open assistant is either
already out there will be coming soon
thank you so much for being here I'll
see you around
thank you
[Music]